[Música]
en directo a América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Juan Pablo
lucum y Juan Pablo qué tal todo muy bien
Andrés Juan Pablo empezamos con noticias
de América Latina empieza a perder ritmo
el aumento en las tasas de interés en
Colombia así es Andrés empezamos
hablando de Colombia el banco de la
República de ese país anunció este
jueves el aumento de 25 puntos básicos
en su tasa de referencia Un aumento que
se esperaba y que aunque ubica los tipos
de interés hasta el 13% la cifra más
alta en 24 años Lo cierto es que van
perdiendo ritmo algunas personas se
preguntarán por qué Sí pues es un
aumento es porque este aumento fue de 25
puntos básicos pero en los meses
anteriores hubo momentos de 100 y 75
puntos básicos el argumento de la
autoridad monetaria de este incremento
moderado fue que la tasa de inflación en
enero y febrero no tuvo un incremento
tan brusco como en 2022 pero el índice
de precios al consumidor todavía sigue
en máximo de pues décadas con el 13,28
interanual como lo estamos viendo en el
gráfico Todavía nos falta el dato de
inflación de marzo que no ha salido pero
pues las tasas ya incluso Pues están ni
velándose a lo que está la inflación en
este momento en el comunicado del banco
de la república se lee abro comillas la
inflación en enero y febrero presentó
incrementos mensuales inferiores a los
observados a lo largo del 2022 la
inflación anual de alimentos inició 2023
con descensos progresivos que la ubican
en febrero en 24,1% sensiblemente por
debajo del dato de diciembre que fue del
27,8% Juan Pablo y es que un escenario
similar se vive en México que también
subió los tipos de interés en 25 puntos
básicos llegaron a una cifra histórica
la cifra histórica son los
11,25% es el máximo histórico al que ha
llegado las tasas de interés en México
esto para tratar de contener la
inflación que aunque es una de las más
bajas de latinoamérica con el 7,62%
interanual de febrero todavía no logran
la reducción del 3%
desesperada por el Banco Central y
decimos que es un incremento histórico
porque pues si vemos el gráfico pues la
tasa llegar al 11,25% y este registro no
se tenía por lo menos en los últimos 15
años lo que quiere decir que Pues
digamos que es como algo nuevo que
empieza a pasar en el país y que también
Pues empieza como una apertura
latinoamérica ahora cuál fue el
argumento de esta entidad para el
aumento vamos a leer precisamente el
documento abro comillas la junta del
gobierno evaluó la magnitud y diversidad
de los choques inflacionarios y sus
determinantes así como la evolución de
las expectativas de mediano y largo
plazo y el proceso de formación de
precios también dijo que con esta acción
se reduce el ritmo de incremento y la
postura de la política monetaria se
ajusta a la trayectoria que se requiere
para que la inflación converja a su meta
del 3% dentro del horizonte de
pronóstico lo vamos al sur de la región
salió el dato de pobreza en Argentina
así es Ese es el dato del segundo
semestre de 2022 Y subió casi tres
puntos respecto al período anterior
la pobreza entonces entre junio y
diciembre se ubicó en torno al
39,2%, lo que se traduce en 11,5
billones de argentinos que están en
situación de pobreza o que también
quiere decir 2,9 millones de hogares en
situación de pobreza también hubo datos
de personas que están en situación en
vigencia con 614 mil hogares en esta
condición lo que quiere decir 2,4
millones de personas en situación de
indigencia datos que dio a conocer hoy
el Instituto Nacional de estadística y
censos de la República de Argentina y
que salieron a partir de una encuesta
que abarcó a 29,3 millones de personas
bien Ahora revisamos el cierre de las
bolsas Y empezamos o más bien
continuamos Hablando de América Latina
porque los principales indicadores de
Argentina México y Brasil cerraron con
ganancias en este último impulsado por
los papeles de la Gigante minera Vale y
la prestación de un proyecto la
presentación de un proyecto de régimen
fiscal con el que el gobierno de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva Busca ajustar las
cuentas públicas Wall Street también con
ganancias luego de semanas de
preocupaciones sobre si el sistema
bancario se estaba deteriorando bajo el
peso de las elevadas tasas de interés
las bolsas europeas también cerraron
reportando ganancias Los indicadores de
París Frankfurt reportaron alzas por
encima del 1% mientras Los indicadores
de Londres tuvo un 0,74% hoy ganancias
en general nos vamos a quedar ahí en
Europa para hablar de las brechas
salariales entre hombres y mujeres en
ese continente Así es este jueves el
parlamento europeo adoptó reglas que
obligan a las empresas a hacer
transparentes con los salarios e imponer
sanciones por discriminación salarial
para las compañías que no cumplan una de
las reglas por ejemplo Andrés es que los
trabajadores puedan exigir conocer los
niveles salariales individuales
desglosados por género otra de las
reglas es que las compañías que tengan
al menos 100 empleados se verán
obligadas a publicar reglamento
regularmente información sobre la brecha
salarial lo que quiere decir que acá por
ejemplo se podría hacer y conocer el
salario de nuestros compañeros usted el
mío el del resto de por ejemplo de la
redacción bueno y Juan Pablo nuestra
cifra del día vamos con dos cifras del
día es una una de ellas es
4.645 pesos colombianos que eso fue lo
que cerró la cotización del dólar en
Colombia este jueves y los 789 pesos
chilenos que esto fue lo que cerró el
dólar Pues en este país ambos vienen de
una Senda bajista desde por lo menos el
20 de marzo cuando se cotizaba un poco
más de 4.800 pesos para el caso de
Colombia y 882 para el caso del pecho
del peso chileno o Pablo lo come con la
información económica Muchas gracias
seguimos con más aquí en directo